I mean you have such a legacy with
Nickelodeon and you've been in this
family for a long time what is it like
for you to come to the Kids Choice
Awards but now as an adult
um it's kind of crazy because it was
such a staple throughout my whole life
getting to come every year
um but it's so much fun I love seeing
all the kids and the energy and it's
definitely one of the most fun award
shows
for sure you're bringing the fun with
this yellow is there any secrets about
this look
um no secrets I just um I feel like this
is a place where you can kind of like
wear whatever and just have a good time
you could be casual you could dress it
up you can do whatever you want at the
Kids Choice Awards you were so good as
the host last year and we're so excited
to see Charlie demilio step into those
shoes have you had a chance to connect
with her or give her any words of wisdom
I haven't but I'm sure she's gonna do an
amazing job but she has so much energy
and she's so great on Tick Tock I love
her videos so I'm sure it's gonna be
great okay I hope you get to meet her
today thank you you know we're so
excited about season three of iCarly
season three of the reboot of iCarly you
know you guys left us with quite an epic
Cliffhanger our Carly and Freddie
finally gonna give it a go in season
three
um I don't want to give it away yet but
um I will say that this entire season
most of the episodes do touch on their
relationship so um there's going to be a
lot of that going on for season three
some more romance in season three
definitely for all the characters but
for Freddy and Carly for sure I love it
and then no big deal you're gonna be
starring with Brooke Shields and
Benjamin Bratt are you excited to put on
these wedding dresses and really embody
a bride I am so excited for so many
reasons but we're filming it in Thailand
which is going to be so fun I've never
been there before and also I can't wait
to meet Benjamin and Brooke that's going
to be amazing um
yeah well Brook's playing my mom yeah
and Benjamin is um playing Brook's old
um High School love so things get
complicated yeah but rom-coms are my
favorite type of movies so it's my first
time ever being in one two so I'm just
so excited oh listen it's a big year for
you you've got a big birthday coming up
it's a big 3-0 I'm so excited for you
because I feel like you just continue to
do cool and unique things what are you
most excited about with turning 30 and
what do you want to achieve I'm most
excited about I mean
I don't know it's just I'm excited to
have a party with my friends I haven't
had a big party since like my 16th so I
think I'm gonna really go for it this
year and really like yes I'm already
thinking about it so um yeah I don't
have a theme yet but just to have like
all my favorite people around and it's
probably gonna be like a huge girls
night because a lot of my friends are
single and so am I so it'll be like a
big fun yeah girls night what are you
most excited to accomplish in this new
decade I'm most excited to accomplish
probably I'm excited for the next season
of the show to come out I'm excited to
get to go on a trip to Thailand For the
First Time by myself and just keep
trying new things
[Music]
foreign